let's say job number one pays you 80,000
a year and you're expected to bring all
the game and build everything and no one
there knows anything about the skill
that you have that you spend a lot of
time learning versus job two is $440,000
a year and there's tons of dudes who are
way ahead of you in that job which one's
the better deal well the answer depends
on your time Rising if you only live one
more year of your life then you should
do the 80 grand but if you think you're
going to live longer than a year or two
then you should do the 40 Grand increase
your earning potential and then later
you right hook life and you can maximize
or realize the potential you've had over
the skills you've stacked